Nancy Pelosi just came out and she said
it is impossible not unlikely not crazy
to think about impossible for Trump to
be president again this is a
neck-and-neck race and no one feels very
comfortable on the Democratic side of
things that Donald Trump isn't going to
be the next
president well I don't think that nobody
feels I think many of us know that it is
impossible uh for him to be the
president again with what he is
proposing well because when you're
talking about what he's talking about
now is more tax cuts for Corporate
America taking them down so low to the
detriment uh of our budget and meeting
the needs of people but people have to
know I have said over and over again
President Lincoln said public sentiment
is everything with it you can accomplish
almost anything without it practically
nothing but public sentiment has to be
informed people have to know you can see
the backtrack happening in real time